zulma y était policier au sein de
l'armée nationale afghane un travail
dont il était fier mais quand il a
compris que le gouvernement allait
s'effondrer il a abandonné sans revenu
depuis il s'est installé dans ce camp de
déplacés avec sa famille
pour survivre il s'est enfoncé dans les
dettes il doit 8500 $ à une famille qui
exigent maintenant le remboursement de
leurs droits dit il il n'a pas d'argent
il va donc offrir en mariage au fils de
18 ans de ses créanciers sa cadette
habiba sept ans se stoppe la famille dit
que c'est mieux qu'elle s'installe déjà
chez eux pour travailler dit il au lieu
de ne rien faire chez moi mais moi je
leur dis qu'il est roux petit travail et
habiba s'accroche à la chemise de son
père il lui a dit ce qui lui arrivait
sans pourtant lui expliquer le détail de
ce que plaisir le mariage
le sait et elle me dit qu'elle ne veut
pas y aller elle est trop petite
vous voyez comme elles mêmes dit il mais
je n'ai pas le choix je dois le faire tu
vois ce lapse curc on note chez renault
la plupart des quelques 300 personnes
qui vivent dans ce camp de misère en
plein coeur de kandahar ont été
déplacées de la province de bagdhis par
les combats des dernières années et la
pauvreté
on ne fait que voir la vie passée
d'izard bibi il n'y a rien ici on ne
vaut rien pour les talibans alors
pourquoi nous aiderez t-il
le mari 2 arbib y aussi emprunté
plusieurs milliers de dollars à des
parents éloignés une dette qu'il faut
éponger sa fille rookie ya huit ans fera
office de paiement pour d'abord une rave
à 9 à la puberté pas de sa mère elle n'a
pas le choix voilà pourquoi je dois leur
donner un allèle c'est une obligation il
n'y a pas d'alternative
assise à ses côtés ou kia ne peut
s'empêcher de sourire elle ne se doute
pas une seconde ce qui l'attend il ne
prête aucune attention la conversation
des grands oraux valachie royal ballet
pour courbis bizi elle ne l'acceptera
pas mais quand ils viendront pour ma
fille je leur donnerai qu'elle le
veuille ou pas à 8 ans c'est impossible
qu'elle en soit heureuse qu'autant
requis roczen à gratot cal mateu le
moment venu à pipi compte mentir
elle me dira qu'elle part vivre chez eux
non pas qu'elle n'a jamais anticipé ce
qui lui arrivera après ne sera plus de
son ressort du tell your tu attends un
mal qui reviennent sais pas comment il
réagira la banane et est sûr qu'elle est
trop jeune pour comprendre sa situation
suis certaine d'izard biblique est à
pleurer et ne pourra pas fêter son sens
il n'y a pas d'âge minimal légal pour le
mariage en afghanistan histoire du temps
de ne pas interférer avec les affaires
familiales pourtant cela n'a pas empêché
les talibans de publier un décret qui
fixe le montant maximal que l'on puisse
payer pour une jeune fille
un peu plus de 5000 $ voilà ce que peut
valoir une jeune promise selon le décret
avant l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
l'âge minimal légal du mariage était
fixé à 16 ans 28% des femmes âgées de 18
à 49 ans ont été mariées avant l'âge de
18 ans selon un rapport publié par
l'unicef en 2018
l'organisme s'inquiète d'une
augmentation marquée du philo ces
derniers mois quand on demande à abdul
rahman combien d'enfants il a il répond
spontanément
c'est au hasard malheureux sept garçons
dit il puis il sera mise il a aussi
trois
défis dit il et 7 garçons au amelot
c'est ma fille ces salles ya huit ans
qui désigne
fois par semaine salle ja se rend à
l'école religieuse pour filles près du
campement ce sont les seules écoles
ouvertes dit sa mère elle y apprend à
réciter le coran mais elle ne s'est pas
l'unir matières de base ne sont pas au
programme
quand on lui demande ce qu'elle aimerait
salia répond timidement qu'elle voudrait
apprendre à écrire car il est un rêve
tout aussi simple qu inaccessible son
père l'a vendu dans le village où il
s'est enfui pilée de dette lui aussi
nous n'avons aucune excuse pour notre
fille dit il le père et la mère sont à
blâmer pas elle pourquoi faudrait-il que
ses parents la donne comme ça elle
devrait se marier minaj correct mais ses
parents doivent de l'argent impossible
négocier il faut payer si le moal à
matemale ahmad vers le but à ses petites
filles qui seront femme sans jamais
vraiment avoir été enfant on ne doit
apparemment rien du tout
c'est marie ève bédard radio-canada
candas